Dominique is in Pittsburgh hi Dominique
how are you thanks for taking my call I
just need to tell you that my husband I
was following her through the village
for 10 years now and it's just amazing
when it's done in our life
Wow very cool how can we help today okay
my I'm really close to Florida I live in
Russia
my dad passed away about two months ago
and she's 73 and she really wants to
downsize the house is too big
it's too hard for her to maintain and so
she was must downsize into an apartment
I really don't know how to advise her
because she's on a very limited income
takes about 10 4,000 a year and if she
was just on the house it'd probably be
about 30 Paula Zahn so I'm not sure what
to say to her is the home paid for yeah
okay and what's it worth 135 you said
okay and what city does she live in okay
well if it's a city that's a reasonable
real estate expense for Honor's I'm
sorry it's a very reasonable area okay
then she should be able to get a condo
for much less than 150 shouldn't she
maybe a hundred thousand hundred ten
thousand dollar condo how is her health
she talked in January she really came
back you know she's walking two miles a
day and her hearing is not really
generating and well the point is that
she's likely to live as much as 30 years
during that 30 years her incomes
probably not going to go up a lot but
rents will
so don't rent okay
buy something okay yeah buy a little
condo and pay cash for it and then she
can make it then she can make it for 30
years on her income the twenty four
thousand I assume includes social
insecurity yeah okay alright so she
doesn't have it and she doesn't have any
other money I soon okay yeah yeah let's
Colette's because you know if she lives
20 years should be 92 she probably won't
live 30 but she'd be 92 right and in 20
think about what rents have done in 20
years
and I don't think our incomes going to
double during that time well I mean I've
offered to have a summer house but she
says she can't take the 110 anymore so
help us save money so yeah I think the
condo is the way to go yeah something
that she can pay cash for and I'm sorry
you lost your dad I'm sorry she didn't
to make these decisions while she's
grieving if there's nothing pushing her
I'd recommend she tap the brakes just a
little bit and maybe way it'll spring
maybe well he's been gone a year and
because you'll make better decisions
after that it's tough to make good
decisions big decisions like this when
you're kind of in the midst of grieving
now if he passed away in the home and
there's you know situation like that
where she didn't want to be in the home
I understand if you want to go and sell
it it's okay but financially it's okay
to whittle spring take your time make
decisions slowly and carefully with
wisdom hey thank you for the call
sorry for your loss this is the Dave
Ramsey show